>> Welcome.
On behalf of Green Google and Authors at Google,
it is my privilege to introduce Dr. Henry
Pollack today.
With his colleagues on the inter-governmental
panel on climate change, Dr. Pollack shared
the 2007 Nobel Peace Prize with former vice
president Al Gore.
Dr. Pollack has been a professor of geophysics
at the University of Michigan for more than
40 years, and has conducted scientific research
on all seven continents.
He now serves as a science advisor to Al Gore's
climate project.
Dr. Pollack is here today to talk about his
latest book, "A World Without Ice.”
Following the talk, we'll have a Q and A session.
And please remember our remote audience at
that time, and use the microphone in the center
aisle when you're asking a question.
And with that, please join me in welcoming
Dr. Henry Pollack.
>> [Clapping]
Dr. Henry Pollack: Hello, everyone.
Thanks very much to Google for the invitation
to come and talk about my new book, "A World
Without Ice.”
I know there's a lot of excitement on the
campus at this very moment with Secretary
of Energy, Steve Chu, announcing the ARPA-E,
new energy grants that are going to play a
big role, we hope, in mitigating the effects
of climate change.
The introduction by your president just a
few moments ago over in the other auditorium
said that, Steve Chu is, you know, someone
who -- you know, some guy with a Scandinavian
accent called early in the morning one day
-- and that, of course, was the reference
to the way in which people learn that they
have won the Nobel Prize.
As you just heard in the introduction that,
the 2007 Peace Prize was shared between Al
Gore, who had half of it, and the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change, which I'm a member,
got the other half.
So people said, "Did you get an early-morning
call from Oslo? Or Stockholm?”
And I said, "No, but I did get one from New
York.”
And they said, "What was that about?”
And I said, "Well, it was a -- kind of a faux,
Scandinavian accent, and it took me about
maybe ten seconds to recognize that it was
my son calling.
He had just heard about the IPCC winning the
Nobel Prize on the radio, and he wanted to
be the first to let me know.
So there he was in his best Norwegian accent,
[imitating accent] "May I speak to Professor
Pollack," and such.
So that's how I learned about the Nobel Peace
Prize.
And I'm sure that Google has lots of Nobelists,
but maybe not two in one day within an hour.
And so, it's a pleasure to be here.
Let me just say a little bit about myself,
and then we'll get to talking about the book.
I'm an Earth scientist: geologist, geophysicist,
climate scientist.
And I teach at a university, and do research
in wonderful places around the globe.
And I've found that it's been a hard sell
persuading the public that climate change
is real and that humans are playing a big
role in it.
These two facts -- that climate change is
real and humans are playing a big role -- are
very apparent to the scientific community.
And yet, there's about half of Americans who
don't believe that it's happening, and certainly
don't think that people have anything to do
with it.
And so, I've -- in addition to my scientific
work -- have tried to reach out and help people
understand the realities of climate change.
And part of that work has been working with
Al Gore -- who, I understand is going to be
here in just a couple of weeks with his new
book, which I had a chance to read and draft
for him about a month ago.
But, I have been working with Al Gore in his
climate project, which is a project that is
designed to train community volunteers to
go out into their hometowns and talk at schools
and churches and rotary clubs -- whatever
audience they can pull together -- and talk
about climate change.
And so, I've been helping him in this training
program of bringing people to Nashville, that's
Al Gore's hometown, and a long weekend of
intense activity.
We send them back, and they become "climate
messengers," as we call them.
So, in that context, I'd also written this
book called, "A World Without Ice.”
And the book is about ice, climate, and people:
the role that ice has played in the development
of our landscape, in the development of Earth's
climate, and its effects on human civilization,
and the reciprocal impact that people are
now having on ice.
A theme interwoven throughout the book is,
Earth's changing climate, both in the past,
present, and in the future.
Now, why ice?
Why did I choose ice as a vehicle to carry
the story of earth's changing climate?
There are three principle reasons that I like
ice.
The first is that, ice plays a big role in
Earth's climate system.
In the polar regions where you have these
big expanses of white ice, basically, ice
is a very good reflector.
Snow is too.
And if you've been skiing, you know you run
the risk of getting sunburned, not from the
sun coming from above, but from the reflection
off of the snow from below will give you a
lot of radiation.
So ice is a very good reflector.
And, as a reflector, it takes sunshine -- that
would otherwise warm earth -- and sends it
right back to space without it doing any warming
at all.
And so, the more ice there is, the less sunshine
Earth receives to warm it; and, the less ice
there is, the more earth receives.
And so, the coming and going of ice is a big
piece of the global climate system.
Secondly, ice is a sensitive and unambiguous
indicator of climate change.
On Earth, ice is very close to its melting
point.
And a few degrees warmer, and you get a substantial
reduction in Earth's ice.
And likewise, if we were to have it be a few
degrees cooler, we would see an expansion
of Earth's ice.
But changes in temperature result in very
visible changes in the distribution of ice
on Earth.
And so ice, as a sensitive indicator, also
is a good vehicle to tell the story of climate
change.
And ice is also neutral as an indicator.
This is the only reading from the book I'll
do for you, but in it, I say that, "Ice asks
no questions; it presents no arguments, reads
no newspapers, listens to no debates.
It's not burdened by ideology, and it carries
no political baggage as it crosses the threshold
from solid to liquid.
It just melts.”
And that's why it is to be an indicator, and
it leads to big changes in the distribution
of ice on Earth with very small changes in
Earth's temperature.
The third reason that I have chosen to tell
this story through ice is that, the consequences
of Earth losing its ice are very big.
The first ice to go will be the glaciers that
sit on top of mountaintops in tropical and
mid-latitude regions.
And they are melting back very, very fast.
The ice on Kilimanjaro, which is very nearly
on the equator, will likely be gone in another
decade.
The ice in the Andes -- the equatorial Andes
and temperate Andes -- is shrinking fast.
Glacier National Park will probably not have
its name sake, glaciers, in another two decades.
The importance of this meltback is that, the
water that comes from melting mountain glaciers
provides the agricultural water and the domestic
water -- drinking and sanitation and the like
-- for about a third of Earth's population,
is a tremendous resource that, once it's gone
-- if you think there are water problems,
water shortages, and certainly you in California
know about water shortages -- you will see
that same story all over the globe.
In the parts of Asia where the water supply
comes from the high Himalayas.
In the Andes where much of Peru, Chile, Bolivia,
their fruit industry, their flower industry.
Much of that will be greatly distressed and
imperiled once the mountain ice is gone.
The other big consequence of melting ice is
that, eventually, it leads to higher sea levels.
When you turn ice into water, the water runs
downhill.
It eventually comes into the ocean, which
alone, will raise sea level.
But, as the oceans themselves are warming
up, as the climate changes, they also thermally
expand.
And that is an additional source of sea level
rise coming from the warming simply through
the physics of expansion of water.
And so, those are the reasons that I've chosen
ice as the vehicle for this book.
Now, I try and develop the story of ice on
Earth as a panorama through time starting
roughly at the peak of the last Ice Age, about
20,000 years ago.
At that time, ice covered all of Canada and
North America, from the Canadian border down
to about the Missouri River in the west, and
the Ohio River in the east.
And in fact, those two rivers were actually
the result of carrying away all of the melt
water from the last Ice Age, and they define
the southern limit of the ice.
In Europe, ice came as far south as about
the midlands in the United Kingdom, and through
Central Europe and the like, and had mountain
glaciers in the Alps.
And, as a result, there was an immense amount
of ice.
But ice and water are what I call, "Playmates
on a Seesaw.”
And, when you have a lot of H2O tied up in
ice, you have much less of it tied up as water.
And so, when you have ice on the continents
starting an Ice Age, you also have much lower
sea levels.
And, in fact, the ocean level at the height
of the last Ice Age, was about four hundred
feet lower than it is today.
And it exposed large swaths of the continental
shelves -- which conveniently provided pathways
for humans to migrate from place to place
and from continent to continent.
The Bering Land Bridge was certainly an important
one.
The English Channel was dry, and so, the communication
between the United Kingdom -- not yet the
United Kingdom but that terrain and continent
of Europe -- was just a walk.
And throughout Southeast Asia there was a
lot of dry land that facilitated human migrations.
And so, the high ice volume, low water level
was a characteristic of the peak of the last
Ice Age.
Now, how about the people?
At that time, they weren't many.
The total population of the globe, about 20,000
years ago, was perhaps on the order of one
million people.
One million people.
Pick out your favorite city with one million
population, but imagine that spread over the
entire globe.
That's the population density of the peak
of the last Ice Age.
Well, now, we have a different situation.
We've come out of the last Ice Age, and we
have seen ice reduced on the globe.
The main places for ice today are on the tops
of the high mountains in the tropics and mid-latitudes,
and in the big icecaps in Antarctica and Greenland,
and then, in the frozen sea ice of the Arctic
Ocean.
The ice on the Arctic Ocean is not very thick,
it's just sea ice that has frozen.
But, those are the main places where we have
ice.
So we have reduced ice, but we have a lot
more people.
From the one million people at the end of
the last Ice Age to the year about 1800, the
growth of population went from one million
to about one billion.
1800 was the year when Earth first reached
the threshold of a billion population.
So that took, let's say, almost 20,000 years.
But the next billion, between 1800 -- the
next billion came in 1930 -- 130 years later.
And the next billion after that came in 1955.
And the next billion after that came in 1974,
when we reached 4 billion people.
And today, we're approaching 7 billion.
And we'll reach 8 billion by 2025, or so.
And 9 billion perhaps at mid-century, depending
on which way the demography goes.
That's a lot of people.
If you were to take Earth's population today
-- close to 7 billion people -- and try and
grasp how many people that really is.
If someone were born every second, and no
one ever died, it would take more than 200
years to produce 7 billion people.
So it's an astounding rate of growth that
we've experienced in just the last couple
centuries.
Not only, of course, do we have a lot of people,
but they're a lot more clever than were the
cave people and the people living on the fringes
of the ice during the last Ice Age.
The people today have learned to use energy.
And I know that, in the other talk by Steve
Chu, the subject of energy usage, the subject
of carbon-based energy, and the need to make
the transition to non-carbon-based energy,
was under heated discussion when I left.
So we have, not only a lot of people, but
they all use a lot more energy, and the energy
let's them make a big impact on the Earth
as a whole.
The landscape of the Earth that we have admired
for a long time -- such as Yosemite Valley
here in California, the Great Lakes in the
Midwest, the Finger Lakes in New York, and
other characteristics around the globe, was
all carved by ice during the last Ice Age.
But today, humans are becoming a big rival
for Earth-moving.
Currently, humans move more earth than rivers
do.
And we have a process of mining going on in
the east today called "mountaintop removal,"
where they simply blast the tops off of almost
five hundred peaks now, or crests, in the
Appalachians, and dump the debris into the
surrounding valleys to be able to mine coal
that's a few meters under the surface.
So humans have become rivals of nature in
the ability to move earth.
We have interfered with the hydrological system
in dramatic ways.
We have dammed every major river in the USA.
There's not an uncontrolled river that flows
to the sea.
No longer.
And we have, not only added all kinds of chemicals
to the environment, but they are eventually
making their way to the sea as well.
Currently, the use of agricultural fertilizers
and the chemicals that accumulate on the impervious
surfaces of our cities and are washed into
the sewer systems by big storms -- those make
their way to the sea, and are today causing
dead zones in the sea where the major rivers
empty into the ocean.
The coast off of Louisiana, where the Mississippi
enters the sea, has very substantial and extensive
dead zones where, effectively, nothing is
living.
We've had big impact on our atmosphere.
We have, you know, created smog that drapes
our cities and acid rain that falls on our
lakes and forests, killing both the trees
and the fish in the lakes.
And, we have used the synthetic chemicals,
the chlorofluorocarbons -- put them to great
use, but later discovered that they were destroying
ozone over Antarctica at a creation of the
Antarctic ozone holes directly linked to our
use of synthetic chemicals.
And among other things that we've been putting
into the atmosphere are the greenhouse gases.
Carbon dioxide is a direct product of burning
the carbon-based fuels: coal, petroleum, natural
gas.
And the carbon dioxide, for the most part,
is going into the atmosphere.
Some of it gets dissolved in the oceans, but
the oceans can't take it up fast enough.
And so, the concentrations of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere have been growing.
We have known, from studies of ice cores,
what the concentration range of carbon dioxide
has been in the past.
Through ice ages and periods between ice ages,
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere has oscillated
between about 200 and 300 parts per million.
Today, the concentration in the atmosphere
is well out of that range of natural variability.
We are at 390 parts per million and adding
two or three parts per million to the atmosphere
every year under our current industrial economy.
And so, humans are embarked on a vast experiment
-- an inadvertent experiment with the chemistry
of our atmosphere -- and the nature of that
chemical experiment is also one that is an
experiment with our climate.
And, because the greenhouse gases trap heat
trying to leave Earth, the atmosphere warms,
the surface warms.
And it is that warming that is having its
impact on the ice of the world.
And so, what is happening to the ice?
As I mentioned earlier, mountain glaciers
everywhere are retreating.
And it's likely that most mountain glaciers
in the world will be gone before mid-century.
We also see big changes in the sea ice of
the Arctic Ocean.
The Arctic Ocean, I mentioned earlier, is
just frozen sea water.
That's the icecap on it.
It's on the order of oh, 15 feet thick in
many places, a little thicker sometimes in
other places.
But in the summertime, there's a little bit
of a breakup of the sea ice in the Antarctic,
until the last few decades when there's far
more than little bit.
The area of sea ice in the Arctic Ocean in
the summer has been shrinking dramatically
over the last few decades, until today, about
only sixty percent of the area of summertime
sea ice that formerly existed is present today,
and its thickness has been reduced by about
half.
The net result of that is that, the Arctic
Ocean is much more open, and the sunshine
that might have been reflected away by the
white sea ice is now being absorbed by the
dark sea water and warming the Arctic Ocean.
What that does is, it prevents the freezing
in the fall.
It pushes it back a few months later into
the fall.
And it also leads to earlier breakup.
So we're on a pathway, I think, to see an
ice-free Arctic Ocean in the summertime in
just a few decades.
And that will be a whole new regime change
in the Arctic.
There will be commercial interests that will
move in very quickly, searching for resources.
There will be fishery ships coming in and
scooping up the Arctic fisheries resource.
There will be trade routes open up.
The fabled "Northwest Passage" and the "Northeast
Passage" will become reality, and lead to
much more sea traffic in the Arctic Ocean.
And so, big changes just due to the loss of
sea ice in the Arctic Ocean.
Then, of course, comes the rise of sea level.
Sea level rice is not something of the future;
it's already happening.
Sea level has risen about eight inches in
the 20th century.
And the projections of the IPCC -- and I'll
come back to how conservative they are in
a minute.
The IPCC said that you can expect another
two feet of sea level rise in the 21st century.
Now, that is far and away a lower bound in
my mind.
Because we're learning a lot of things about
how rapidly ice is leaving Greenland and Antarctica,
and popping into the ocean.
The IPCC calculation of what we could expect
in sea level was basically a melting calculation:
How fast Greenland would melt, how fast Antarctica
would melt, and that water would eventually
make its way to the sea.
But you don't need to wait for ice to melt
to raise sea level.
If you drop an ice cube into a beverage glass,
you'll see that the level in the beverage
glass rises right away.
And we're now witnessing wholesale loss of
ice from both Greenland and west Antarctica.
Greenland has the equivalent of about 20 feet
of sea level rise with its ice and West Antarctica
the same.
East Antarctica is a much bigger pile of ice,
and it stands much higher.
And it's going to take a lot more to destabilize
that.
But Greenland and West Antarctica are already
losing their ice at faster rates than the
IPCC had predicted.
Now, the IPCC understood why its projections
were on the low side.
Because, already, the rapid acceleration of
ice off of Greenland was visible and the same
in West Antarctica.
And the reason being that, there is a lot
of summertime melting of the top of the ice
sheet, and the water was finding its way down
through fishers to the base of the ice sheet
and lubricating the base of the ice sheet.
And it was slipping off much faster than simply
melting from the top.
In the Antarctic, some of the big ice shelves
that are simply glacial ice that spilled off
the continents onto the sea -- they too are
becoming unstable, because the sea water is
warming and eroding them from below and thinning
them and breaking them up.
And so, my guess is that, we're more likely
to see something on the order of three to
six feet of sea level change in the 21st century.
Now, what would that mean?
What would three feet of sea level change
mean?
Well, it means that you would lose about the
southern 20 percent of Florida.
It would be reclaimed by the sea.
All of the Florida Keys would be gone.
Much of the gentle, Atlantic seacoast of the
Carolinas and Georgia would see big incursions
of the sea.
But the human tragedy is big.
If you look at how many people live within
three feet of sea level the world over, you'll
discover that the number's about 100 million.
And we experienced the social problems of
dealing with dislocated people, with the people
in New Orleans, following Hurricane Katrina.
We had about a 150,000 people that were climate
refugees.
The number of people affected by three-foot
rise in sea level is about 100 million people
worldwide.
And that's a social challenge and international
challenge of the first order.
And it gives urgency to all of the things
that Secretary Chu is talking about in the
other auditorium just a few moments ago.
Some people say that we should not let the
concentration of greenhouse gases reach beyond
450 parts per million -- that really bad things
start to happen then.
Currently, we are at 390, and increasing at
around three parts per million every year.
Well, you can do the arithmetic.
I know that people at Google are good at doing
arithmetic.
There's sixty parts per million to work with,
and if we're adding three parts every year
-- that gives us about two decades to stabilize
our emissions of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere.
And, that may sound like a long time, but
two decades to totally reinvent the energy
usage -- energy supply -- around the world,
is a big challenge.
Now, I was listening to Secretary Chu, and
he was asked the question, "Well, are you
optimistic?”
And in some ways, I am optimistic.
Because I know that, once you get people's
attention in serious ways, that they can respond
very impressively.
I'm old enough to remember World War II when
U.S. was suddenly hit over the head with a
two by four.
That was our entry into World War II.
And, all the best at industry was ended and
converted to a wartime industry.
No more passenger automobiles.
No more refrigerators.
No more appliances.
Every bit of industry was turning to build
airplanes, tanks, vehicles, artillery.
And, in just one year, the transformation
was so dramatic, that one aircraft factory
near my hometown in Michigan -- one aircraft
factory -- was making more airplanes than
all of Japan.
And that was a transformation of dramatic
proportions.
But it took something to get our attention.
And I think that we need to pay attention
now.
That's one of the reasons that I wrote the
book.
And it's one of the reasons that I try and
talk in various venues around the country
-- even around the world for that matter.
To make people very aware that we don't have
a lot of time to dillydally, and that there's
a real sense of urgency in making a transformation
to non-carbon-based energy.
If we do that, we'll still be able to retain
our ice.
If we don't do that, then you're going to
get what I have as the title of my book, a
World Without Ice.
With that, I'm going to stop talking.
And I'd love to have some discussion with
you, and to hear your thoughts and your questions.
And let's have a good chat.
Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]
Dr. Henry Pollack: What's the custom here
at Google?
Does anyone just stand up and go to the mic,
or whatever?
All right.
We have a volunteer.
Q So, I think one difficulty that we face
on this issue is basically communicating sort
of, What exactly the sort of global threat
that we're envisioning if we get to 450 parts
per million to the general population?
Because it seems kind of abstract.
Dr. Henry Pollack: Well, it does.
And the reason that ice may not be a perfect
medium is that, the ice is a long way away
from where the people are, but the sea level
change affects the entire globe.
And so, the task is to have people be aware
that, what seems to be a remote issue, in
fact, is one that has very direct consequences.
Q And, just to follow up, so it sounds like,
based on what you're saying that, kind of,
the direction that we're headed is maybe losing
lots of ice whether we get to 450 or not.
Or maybe that's only if we get to 450, then
that's going to start happening.
Dr. Henry Pollack: No, it's already happening.
We don't want it to go beyond that threshold.
Some actually think 350 is the proper threshold.
We're already past that.
They want to return as quickly as possible.
Bill McKibben is one who advocates that.
But, I think that the answer -- the real question
you're asking -- is, we have to translate
this into issues that are closer to home that
people do understand.
And, in that context, I think that the global
financial crisis is a stroke of luck.
Sorry that, you know, for all the people who
are out of work, that's no stroke of luck
at all.
But it is kind of the lack in the head that
I speak of where people say, "Gee, everything
we've been doing suddenly doesn't seem like
we really knew what we were doing.
So, maybe we can take bold steps now.”
And Al Gore said something like, you know,
"Our dependence on foreign oil and the security
issues associated with that, our status as
the world's largest debtor nation, our financial
instability around the world, and climate
change are not four separate problems.
They're all four facets of the same problem
-- a misguided, national energy policy.”
So I admire the way that Steve Chu and his
colleagues in Washington are focusing on energy.
If we get our energy policy right, that's
something everyone understands locally.
They don't have to think about polar ice to
get the message.
So having that now as a vehicle to get people's
awareness and their creativity thinking -- going
-- I think is a good step.
Q Hi.
Dr. Henry Pollack: Hi.
Q Thank you so much for coming.
Dr. Henry Pollack: Thank you.
Q So, if you see that a lot of these things
are already happening, and you could see the
change, my first question is, How do you still
sleep at night if you know that this was all
coming?
Dr. Henry Pollack: Well, it's a good question,
because I'm as concerned as any.
And I don't lose sleep over it, but I do think
about it and try and think of, "What can I
do differently to reach more people to develop
an awareness?”
And so, while -- as I say, I'm not losing
sleep, but it has energized me during the
day to explore as many avenues as possible.
And one of them, I should say, is that, people
say, "Well, what can I do individually to
help mitigate climate change?”
And, of course, you heard all of it.
You know, we want to have our houses more
energy efficient.
We want to have our transportation more energy
efficient.
We want to change lightbulbs.
We want to drive less.
We want to choose where we live so we don't
have to commute so much.
And all of those are important, personal decisions.
I've even become aware of -- even rethinking
your eating habits is something that can have
a big impact.
Because, of course, there's so many of us,
and choices among foods have very real, energy
implications.
But, I still think that the problem is so
big that it won't come from volunteers or
more individual choice.
We need both state and national policies and
international policies that become from our
elected representatives, and so your vote
is very important.
If the people that go to Congress that represent
you aren't representing you on this issue,
you should let them know that.
And let them know, if there's an election
in 18 months, or whatever, and if they don't
establish a track record, you know, we're
going to work hard to move you out.
So votes are important, and communicating
your impatience with your elected representatives
is important.
They do understand that they have to get reelected.
And, if you cast it just that starkly, that
plays a big role.
We're not going to do it individually; we're
going to do it through national and international
policy and leverage.
Thank you.
Q Hi. I was wondering if you could -- I know
this is a complex subject -- but try and explain
the cooling and warming model a little bit.
Because -- to me, who is sort of untrained
in this -- ice and carbon seem like two different
things.
And if we factor out people, you know, you
talked about reflectivity, and that completely
makes sense.
I can see that.
But, if I apply that to the past Ice Age,
it would seem like, "Oh, we'd never warm up
again.
Because as the ice got thicker and thicker,
we'd get more and more reflective, and then
there'd be nothing to tip the balance back.”
And so, there must be something.
And so, I was wondering if you can kind of
unify that model?
Dr. Henry Pollack: Yeah, well, it's not my
unification.
It has been, of course, studied intensively.
And, in fact, ice ages do end.
And they're followed by rapid warming.
But part of the end of ice ages has to do
with orbital factors in the Earth and its
orbit about the sun.
And that, the tilt of the Earth's axis -- which
is today about 23 and a half degrees from
the plane of our orbit about the sun -- that
actually oscillates between 21 and 24 degrees.
And the shape of the ellipse about the sun
oscillates with a period about 100,000 years.
And the procession of the equinoxes, which
determines which hemisphere is getting more
sunshine in June or December -- that has a
period in the low 20,000 years.
And those factors are the big pacemakers of
the ice age.
But, what we've noticed is that -- throughout
the ice ages -- temperature and carbon dioxide
have marched together.
Now, the lesson of that is that, the two are
strongly coupled.
That the temperature and the carbon cycle
are tied together.
And whenever either one gets out in the lead,
it pulls the other along.
So, if the temperature were to warm, it would
pull the carbon dioxide up.
If the carbon dioxide is added, quite independently
of temperature, it would pull the temperature
up.
In the current world, we are pulling carbon
dioxide way out ahead of temperature, and
the temperature is starting to catch up.
And so, yes, there are the long period, orbital
factors that play a role, but right now, we
are pulling carbon out of the Earth, and sending
it back to the atmosphere at a pace that it
hasn't seen for over a million years -- probably
many million years.
Q So I can imagine how we can adapt to rising
sea levels and missing ice.
I'm more concerned about ocean acidification.
I wonder if you have any insider words to
add about how dramatically the ecology of
the oceans will shift as the pH drops?
Dr. Henry Pollack: Well, there's quite a well-established,
observational data about the slow decline
in the pH.
And the oceans are still not acidic in the
technical sense, but they're approaching -- they're
becoming less alkaline and approaching acidity.
And that, of course, does affect any of the
organisms that use calcification as the way
of building their shells or their reefs or
whatever.
We're just beginning to see studies that show
that coral reefs are having trouble.
Some of the bivalves on the ocean floor -- their
shells are thinning.
And so, it's at a stage now where you're getting
all the early warning signs.
But, just as we need to stabilize our emissions
into the atmosphere -- after all, that is
what is driving the decrease in pH in the
oceans is that, the oceans are asking to absorb
more and more of the carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere, and they do that, but it's changing
the pH.
Where it's going to take us is not so clear
to me.
I'm not a biologist, and I don't have that
insight.
But, it's a very real problem, because the
marine environment, of course, is a huge source
of human nourishment, and to see that be impacted
in this way is ominous.
Now, I might add that there are schemes afoot
to block sunshine.
It's called geo-engineering or climate-engineering,
by putting artificial pollution into the atmosphere
to reflect sunshine away or to spray water
vapor into the atmosphere to promote cloud
formation.
All of that is to, kind of, mechanically interfere
with sunshine reaching the Earth, but that
doesn't do anything for the problem you cited.
If we're still pumping out carbon dioxide
and trying to adjust climate by reducing sunshine,
the carbon dioxide is still going to go into
the ocean and lead to a drop in pH.
So I think that the geo-engineering or climate-engineering
solutions are shortsighted if they focus only
on blocking sunshine.
Q Apologies if you covered this earlier in
your talk, but methane is one of the other
large contributors to effects in the atmosphere.
And we have, you know, billion of tons of
biomass in the Arctic that's thawing out and
letting methane out.
It seems to me that could have a pretty disastrous
impact on the behavior of the atmosphere and
I was wondering.
Dr. Henry Pollack: The comment that, as the
regions around the Arctic are thawing out,
the permafrost degrading.
And that, there's a lot of methane locked
in the permafrost that's making its way to
the atmosphere.
And that's all true.
And there is also methane stored in ice just
below the ocean floor, which has a huge amount
of methane that, if it were destabilized and
went into the atmosphere that, it too, would
add to the greenhouse gas burden of the atmosphere.
About the melting of the permafrost -- once
again, kind of the first stage of measurements
in the permafrost lakes that are developing
-- show -- yes, indeed -- there is a methane
flux.
And how fast that will penetrate -- the melting
will penetrate -- and release more, is the
big question.
Most calculations of the diffusion of heat
downward to melt the permafrost and release
the methane, shows that it's not a fast problem.
It's one that would progress slowly and have
a time scale that would be in the centuries,
rather than an immediate belching out of large
amounts of methane.
So while it's nothing to trivialize, it's
not something that's going to overwhelm us
with a very fast and furious feedback into
the greenhouse.
Q I was, I guess, looking more at the Arctic
climate in Siberia as opposed to the one in,
say, northern Canada, because the biospheres
there were tremendously different.
Dr. Henry Pollack: Well, the area that's been
studied -- at least that I'm familiar with
is, in fact, the Siberian permafrost.
That's where these early measurements that
I was describing first were made -- I'm sure
the Canadians are active too.
But as you pointed out, maybe it's quite a
different biosphere.
So I can't offer a lot of insight into that,
other than to say that, I think that the physics
of the destabilization is fairly slow. Yes?
Q Hi. I think it's great that there is more
consciousness, you know, around our problems
and people are changing habits and there is
progress being made, but I still worry very
much about the rate of that kind of progress
when you talk about hundreds of millions of
billions of people being added to the Earth.
When you talk about we're only sixty million
parts away from a really nasty threshold and
we're rising quickly.
You talked about how quickly the -- in your
point on being optimistic -- you saw what
happened in your town with the conversion
to military industrial capability.
Where's the Pearl Harbor, though, that's going
to help us out this time?
Dr. Henry Pollack: Where is the Pearl Harbor?
Where is the two by four that gives us the
whack?
I can envision two by fours.
I can envision, for instance, a large dislodgement
of ice from Greenland that would raise sea
level, you know, maybe three or four inches
at one time.
That could happen, and three or four inches
is a lot.
When you think of what it means and increasing
the strength of any storm that strikes the
seashore.
The storm surges are bigger; the tides are
bigger.
Everything about it suddenly is augmented
by this half foot of sea level rise.
That maybe would get attention.
It's hard to know what kind of an earthquake
that it would take to say, "Wow, this is,
you know, we really have to do something about
it.”
And part of that, I think, has to do with
-- people don't consider themselves strong
in the face of nature -- that they are wowed
by earthquakes, that they've seen their actions
before, and that they say, "Woe is me.
You know, hurricane or tsunami or an earthquake.
You know?
Who am I in the face of powers of nature?”
But what they don't realize is that, collectively,
all -- almost seven billion -- of us are now
the most powerful, geological force on the
planet.
And it's that awareness that has to shift.
And that's a tough one, because it's a cognitive
problem.
It's a sociological problem.
It's not quite the same as a surprise attack.
>> So I wanted to thank you for coming to
Google today.
And, for those of you who got books, he'll
be signing books over there after this.
So, thank you for coming.
>> [clapping]
Dr. Henry Pollack: Thank you.
>> It's wonderful.